[Music]
thank you very much can you hear me yes
I hope so
okay so I'm very very happy to be here
first of all I'm very very happy you are
here I can see that my simple trick
marketing trick with a keyword real
money in the title works it's very very
good so I will I want to show you a high
level story of about several real-world
use cases applications of data science
or maybe data analytics in general in
the real world business business
problems but first a few words about me
and SAS Institute so I work for SAS
Institute right now SAS Institute right
now is a one of the biggest and oldest
company that deals with data analytics
so it was founded more than 40 years ago
in the u.s. more than 25 years we are
working in Poland but in general SAS is
a global global company and in fact most
of big companies like top 500 fortunes
fortunes list companies there are our
customers most of them are our customers
so we we can talk about real real life
applications I think and I personally
work as a business solutions manager in
SAS so I I I seek opportunities business
new business opportunities seek for new
business opportunities mostly in the
field of advanced analytics for
telecommunications banking manufacturing
energy so the domain is quite quite wide
and also a short comment before before
SAS I worked for many years in at the
university I did a PhD then I did a
postdoc in the field of artificial
intelligence then I worked for Samsung
currenty did a lot of interesting stuff
with open source playing with deep
learning and so on
so I'm not very focused on South
technology I'm
more open-minded for all themselves for
example okay so what is the goal of the
presentation so I've observed that
there's a gap between universities and
high tech companies and industry and by
industrial I mean all the companies that
there are not universities and there are
not high tech companies so that they are
not Google there are not Facebook they
are not startups they are just companies
with which core business is different
than the ninety so banks telecoms but
also manufacturing logistics sense and
so on and I'm not the only one who
observed this gap so we heard a nice
talk in the morning but in the morning
about that so there are many reasons but
I'm talking about my perspective and my
private personal maybe observation so
when I talk to data scientists my
friends I think that most of them maybe
not all of them but most of them thinks
that industry in general is is boring
right now they are partially right there
are a lot of topics in industry like
data preparation integration cleaning
explaining with with business with
customer what the data means actually
and then it takes most of your time and
then you have I don't know few days or
two weeks for modelling so you use basic
models like regression decision trees or
I don't know and that's it so you can
say that it's boring from that from
perspective of a person who who is
younger data scientist for examples so
he prefers to take a cackle competition
and just do some nice stuff with deep
neural networks instead of going to the
industry and doing industry projects and
this is also the reason why industry
when we are talking to industry we are
we are talking about new new new new
ideas new techniques machine learning
techniques they just don't understand us
they think we are kind of aliens they
have the simple problems they have they
believe they have some simple data then
so they don't don't get that they don't
get the potential of the of the new
technology so when we are talking about
about artificial intelligence
it's like the different world world for
them so they don't invest money they
don't invest money in this sophisticated
technologies which makes them even more
boring from our perspective and you know
that's that's the problem one of the
problems that causes this gap so what
are the possible possible solutions
first of all where we can show to the
industry how how these techniques can
help so that's that's what we do every
day almost so I go to the customers and
I try to get data from from from them
and work with the data and show that
there are new techniques that give them
new new opportunities and on the other
hands I think that it's good to show to
the community from time to time that not
every project for the industry must be
boring so there's my goal for today just
present a several selected use cases
that in my opinion from some reason they
are just interesting can be interesting
for us so let's let's start with the
first case it's something that we call
that we call analytics at the edge there
will be a concrete example but first
what's this edge what's this analytics
at the edge so here you can see then
here we can see the basic approach to
analytics or even big data analytics so
the basic approach is that you have some
sources of data you first access the
data store the data somewhere maybe in
Hadoop maybe in a big large database and
then you processes process the data in
batch and then then basing on basing on
this processing you you generates an
output like reports maybe models that
can be used for scoring customers and so
on but within this case that I'm talking
about right now
we have a different type of data and
different different date so we have we
are talking about streaming data so a
new type of data appears that is
streaming all the time and streaming
from like if you imagine the IOT
environment
from millions of sensors and now the
question is should we really take all
the data and store it and then analyze
it so there's at least two reasons why
we should do do it in an other way one
is that if we want to react very quickly
then just this whole process takes too
long and another reason is that baby if
the data is coming continuously from
from sensors then it's it's not a good
idea to to store all the data and
otherwise ordered all the data maybe
it's better to move analytics closer to
the source of the data and then perform
some may be simple or even not so simple
analytics there and just move only there
let's say interesting part of the data
to our storage and then process is in a
more sophisticated way so this is more
or less more or less the approach of
other mixes or into analytics so we want
to move the analytics closer to the
source of the data and this is this is a
sample architecture that I would like to
describe sorry I would like to describe
which implements this idea together
together with Cisco we've created this
architecture so it why it moves okay I
won't use the pointer maybe this will
help
no I don't know why it happens like this
so we have like two two places where
analytics can take place it can can work
can be executed one is this edge so when
we have sensors then probably they will
they will connect to the central data
data center with some routers and the
key idea here is to put to put a piece
of software in this case our piece of
software that performs stream analytics
it can filter out some data it can
aggregate data it can detect simple
patterns but also it can apply some
scoring using
using a trained model we train model it
can do its directly on the router so the
first the first level of analytics goes
goes here on the router then the data is
going to data center
and in the data center of course we have
a bigger cluster that can perform some
more sophisticated more complicated
analytics yeah and this is in general
this is a Cisco validated design so this
architecture was was tested and violated
by Cisco and certified by by Cisco okay
let me start a short video here so this
is the use case for this for this
application imagine we have a tracks the
tracks have have sensor sensors onboard
tens or even more than 100 of sensors
onboard and they are streaming data and
the data is initially analyzed on board
on the track so some patterns are
detected there some alerts are generated
there and the data the data is also
transferred to the basis Data Center if
it is interesting so let's say that if
nothing happens that it doesn't make
sense to transfer all the readings from
sensors to the data center because it's
it's cost you just to push this data
through the network so if nothing
happens then from time to time we send
some information to the data center but
if if we detect some events if we detect
some patterns that are interesting then
we we change we changed operations so
first first of all we we are sending
more data because it's increasing data
we want to store it and analyze it in
the future and second we generate alerts
that can cause some actions okay so the
the use case the the business context of
this use case it is a leading
manufacturer of tracks I can't tell you
which one but is one of the biggest
world producers of tracks and the
business goal is to reduce warranty
costs the secondary goal is actually to
to be more to be to be more competitive
with so the
competitors of this track manufacturer
also wants to sell tracks so this
company seeks for new opportunities to
reduce costs to provide better service
to increase the uptime of their tracks
which is crucial for their customers so
transportation firms transportation
companies for example the results more
less art here so we've implemented if
we've used up our solution using mostly
out-of-the-box functionality with with
very little of coding here and we reduce
the downtime for tracks by up to 30 30
30 % we also created quite nice
prediction models that could predict the
failures of particular parts in a truck
with very high accuracy even 30 days
before their failure occurs so it's also
quite quite important and in general the
the costs were reduced by 20 20 percent
so it's millions of dollars you can
imagine I will give you some more
numbers later about the number of tracks
and so on this is a simple screen of
course it's for the visualization of
data in the data center so here you can
see data from which which can be online
in real time
read read from from tracks for example
we are monitoring turbo boost and oil
temperature and our system on onboard
system when it detects two peaks
correlated with each other at the same
time so that means that that tarp turbo
needs to be maintained it needs to be
checked so the alert is generated and
it's sent it sends to the data center
and to the manufacturer and then it can
it can arrange maintenance action in our
another example the air temperature is
monitored and the ABS braking system is
also monitored here when we when we see
the wheel slip and we know that the
temperature
around zero then we can generate a load
for the driver that conditions are
dangerous on the road and also which is
not implemented yet we can we can
implement some kind of vehicle to
vehicle communication to inform other
tracks around that there's a problem so
some interesting details during training
we had a training data from a fleet of
forty thousand trucks each truck was
equipped with more than sixty sensors
generating more than ten thousand
measurements per vehicle every single
day it was all historical data so that's
where we created some models these
models were then deployed in our
component to this one onboard component
on on the track to detect these events
these patterns interesting patterns for
example I mentioned that our software
was installed on on the Cisco router mmm
sorry for this Polish part inflated okay
another one yes I was talking about this
so I will not repeat that the same
architecture the same the same
cooperation between cisco routers and
our software was implemented in another
use case for a European energy company
then ESP our event stream processing
engine was monitoring a smart grid
operation of a smart grid okay so that's
it about the first case second case is a
real-time fraud detection in banking so
I will show the architecture on the next
slides but first I can show you our our
customer it's a public reference so you
can go and check some more details on
the website it's a Polish bank big big
Polish bank as you know probably and
they this bank in
very complete for anti-fraud system
composed of many components and I will
focus on this component related to the
real-time fraud detection so when we are
making some transactions like in the
electronic channels some transfers then
each transfer is automatically in
real-time scored by by the system and
potentially some of the transfer may be
may be delayed or blocked if the fraud
if a fraud this is detected it's a nice
also a nice example of end-to-end and
the complete solution analytical
solution for our customers so in general
we can say that we have two phases when
we are working with data for our
customers there's a discovery phase
that's that's what we like right so we
can of course we need to access data but
then we can explore the data model data
that's that there's the sexy part let's
say but there's also another another
part and this part is easily easily
available using open source solutions
but there's also another part and we as
a SAS are trying to address also this
part which is which is deployment so in
fact we not only provide tools to
analyze data but we provide interfaces
and tools to to implement to implement
the results of the ten of these analysis
so we provide tools for analyst analysis
in bank fraud analyst in bank so they
can design test and simulate so called
fraud scenarios and rules used later to
detect frauds so they can do it and use
it using some visual interfaces we also
provide software to to monitor to
monitor and to analyze alerts so if our
if the rules are deployed deployed here
using automaticall tools detect some
routes then we have an interface for for
for analysts to check if this fraud is
really really a true fraud or is it a
false positive
and of course we can integrate with
banking system and then block
transactions and start some procedures
related to this to this fraud and
eventually avoid losing money so this is
more or less how it looks in more more
in detail so we have here we have some
core banking systems sending
transactions in real time here we have a
first first component for stream
processing this is in mome in-memory
stream processing and it takes this
transactions data it combines it in
memory with some customer data loaded
earlier in in batch mode stew to memory
with a customer profile then the this
transaction is go to scoring they are
scored using some rules I will mention
later where these rules come from and
then our lives are generated and as I
mentioned that the transactions may be
blocked or passed if nothing is is
detected and here we have another
component of imported component of the
system so we have historical data store
also all the alerts all the transactions
go here and are stored here for future
analysis and we have a system to perform
this analysis so here we have a part of
the system to visualize and report the
status of the systems but but the system
but we also have a component for for
visual as I mentioned before for visual
designing and testing and simulated
simulating the rules that later can be
deployed directly to this operational
engine so analysts work here they try to
detect the rules simulate them if they
decide that this rule is really a good
rule to detect fault
using our interface they can deploy it
on the fly to the system which works all
the time for for 24 hours a day okay so
that's more or less how it looks like
inside and a similar system is realized
in is implemented in the Picatta
let me come to the to the last part of
of examples telco data and some problems
that we meet in our with our
telecommunications customers so typical
problems solved by telco operators in
Poland and not only in Poland all things
like maybe you know these names trend
prediction so we are trying to predict
if a customer mobile Mobile customer a
mobile phone owner will cancel the
contract and move to our competitor for
example propensity to buy so standard
standard standard standard problem to to
score offers and repair best offers and
some other and some other common
problems and there is also a typical
approach in telco industry they did many
years before when it went was created so
so called analytical base base table is
created and it's it's basically a long
vector of data describing for example a
customer and it's created mostly by
experts so we decide what kind of
aggregates what kind of data what kind
of transfer transformed variables are
put into this works or this vector and
then this vector is used for prediction
when we add some gold let's say that the
customer will churn next month we can
build this training date in data and
train our models usually we also select
some features from abt we do not use the
whole abt because it's really wide so
it's like thousands of of features we
train models and the problem is that
these parts are already done manually so
when you experts needs to decide what
vectors put here what features to choose
so I I briefly described a few
approaches that we took try to take to
to solve the problem of this manual
manual actions so first one is using a
deep autoencoder
so we used a deep autoencoder to to trim
I don't know if you know anything about
it but I don't have time to explain it
it's basically a neural network that can
compress the input the inputs the input
vector which can which can be our abt
vector to a small representation in this
simple example we compress this
representation to only ten features and
it's quite quite effective in this
compression then we can train a
classifier on these features and when we
compare the results to to the model
created according to this the standard
procedure where experts selected 75
features and trained model using similar
technique then using this compressed
representation improved improve the
overall result of the prediction model
of course we do not use it in an
isolated environment so in fact we we
can what we do is we we can use it to
generate these additional features that
are added to the ABT and then mmm then
we can use some I mean experts can use
them so can choose not only from these
features but also from this highly
informative compressed features or we
can perform some automatic feature
feature selection and usually for
example can use gradient boosting to do
that and usually some of these features
are combined with these features and
then the results are better comparing to
the standard approach another idea that
we were considering is to to change to
change this abt concept and to replace
this predefined aggregates aggregates
with some generic aggregates like we are
not saying that for each customer we
need to aggregate his spendings from the
last month and from the last free month
and from the last half-year
but we we built some generic aggregates
like daily aggregates and then we use a
deep network to to create its own
representation basing on the data so we
are giving some micro micro aggregates
we are giving some target and
the network does the job of building
building this abt and building the
representation time okay that's the last
this the last one the last case is for
events sequence discovery it's quite hot
topic recently because we we are
implementing in for several customers we
are implementing real-time marketing
systems when the market where the offers
are sent in response to some events and
these events are defined by experts for
now so we say that let's say I will
receive a call from former competitors
and I'm close to the end of my contracts
and then it is a event and then
automatically automatically I get a SMS
or contact from from call center but the
problem is that we would like to to find
find out in from data what should be the
event patterns that we should react to
so we should find these events
automatically or the sequences of events
automatically and then recurrent neural
networks can help so again I don't I
won't go into details but here instead
of building this ABT tables with
information about events we are using
recurrent networks that update for each
customer the this network can update its
internal state representing the state of
this customer and then training this
these type of networks with data for all
customers and giving also training
signal so we are giving a sequence of
events and training signal 0 or 1 so by
not by trend not churn we can achieve a
presentation which is a really good
representation for representing the
state of a customer and that can be used
to classify this customer later so
that's the city bar if we are talking
about the use cases few words of about
our platform so we are using SAS mostly
and most of these techniques despite
described are available in SAS
particularly in the latest
new analytical engines via so I
recommend you to check it out I'll give
you a link in a moment and what is
important is that there was a stereotype
that sass is a closed system so if you
want if you want to use sass you need to
know such language so here here it's
completely different approach so we open
open up for four new technologies we can
you can easily use our our components
using Python Java R or web services yes
so we can use our visual interfaces our
program language our programming
language or your favorite language to
use our our analytical system you can
also use Python I will not go into
details again but you can do it if you
need I don't have time right so the last
information is the link where you can
check it out more information and some
trial version that you can you can you
can test so two things I would like to
remember after this presentation I hope
I convinced you that there are some
industrial applications that may be
quite interesting for us that's the
first thing and the second one is that
you can use sass with open source
technologies together starting from few
month before you can you can do it ok
thank you so much
we have time for a short question sorry
if I miss that but you probably promised
us to talk about more about scoring in
that fraud anti-fraud system become more
about scoring how do you score if the
transaction is router or not yeah so
this is a kind of a hybrid approach it's
not that easy to describe it it's in
fact based on rules expert rules against
so as I mentioned there is a team of
analysts that is analyzing data
including historical frauds and they are
building some rules and these rules can
be enriched with outputs from some
predictive models so you can also train
some neural network for example to
detect a particular particular type of a
fraud and then you have something like a
scorecard when you combine the results
of Rize of models and these rules into a
single score right and this core this
core Disko determines the risk of a
fraud thank you it's worked it works
more or less like that okay one more
today it was very interesting the
examples you gave what what's not very
clear to me is if you a python user and
why would someone use SAS what what's
the advantage over the other modules
what makes difference so yes that's
that's a big the bigger story of what we
can offer to ask our customers so I
mentioned about that a little bit so
first of all we have large customers
like telcos and banking's with big huge
teams of analysts that are using our
technology they are using our interfaces
including visual interfaces so I didn't
mention visual interfaces here we have a
lot of visual interfaces to visually
explore the data model the data and so
on
and the second part is the deployment
part so we have like ready solutions
that allow you to deploy all
systems integrated with I don't know a
bank transaction systems and so on so in
fact if you are a data scientist and he
wants to test some new hypothesis you
don't need to SAS for that probably
right but if you work for a company and
you know that later in order to deploy
your model you will need to integrate
with the whole ecosystem then you can
you can just create create this model
using your preferred technology you can
use SAS for evaluate models for deploy
morals there are a lot of scenarios okay
thank you okay thank you so much we hope
for your talk thank you very much
[Applause]
you